[Música]
Colombia fue la primera parada del
secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken en su gira en América
Latina que lo llevará hasta chile y Perú
en su encuentro con Gustavo Petro la
política de drogas fue la protagonista
esto medio de las preocupaciones por la
nueva política en esta materia por parte
del presidente colombiano sale vamos a
Daniel que les analista para América
Latina del cato instituto gracias Daniel
por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia de 4 está mañana de
martes hablemos entonces de la
superioridades que busca Anthony blinken
en nuestra región de América Latina y el
Caribe en general para para después ir
enfocándonos en varios puntos de una
visita de cada país
Buenos días Pues según los funcionarios
del departamento de estado lo que está
tratando de hacer el secretario es
demostrar que a una interés por la
región en particular por estos tres
países de Suramérica Colombia Perú y
chile que visitará y sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta digamos el gran avance que ha
habido desde el punto de vista de china
en los últimos años en la última década
no solo la relación es diplomáticas sino
también en la gran inversión hoy en día
china es el principal país inversionista
en la región y esto por supuesto
preocupa a Estados Unidos digamos con
este viraje estos tres países a
gobiernos de izquierda Daniel preocupa a
Estados Unidos O que ya no sea como
digamos uno de los principales socios de
estos de estas tres naciones sino pues
naciones más afines a regímenes de
izquierda a gobiernos de izquierda mejor
dicho
Pues yo creo que depende de cada país en
el caso de Colombia pues sigue siendo
Estados Unidos el principal socio
comercial por lejos y como mencionabas
obviamente está en la discusión el tema
de las drogas sobre todo después del
discurso de Gustavo Petro en Naciones
Unidas
hace una o dos semanas en mi opinión
este tema ha sido un poco
sobredimensionado porque lo único que ha
hecho Petro es decir que se requiere un
nuevo enfoque global para la guerra
contra las drogas lo cual En mi opinión
es cierto pero eso también era lo que
decía por ejemplo el expresidente Juan
Manuel Santos y en materia ya de
políticas públicas a nivel de Colombia
Pedro realmente no ha hecho nada más
allá del tema de la extradición
básicamente decir que va a dejar de
extraditar narcotraficantes a Estados
Unidos pero lo demás ha mantenido
exactamente la misma política que había
antes no va a haber entonces un cambio
drástico como pensarían a analistas
políticos y también en la población
general de Colombia hablando este punto
específico
la política antidrogas a que quiere
llevar a cabo el gobierno del presidente
Gustavo Petro porque hay tanto digamos
cautela en la población y también a
nivel a nivel internacional por lo que
quiere o lo que quiere es lo que quería
hacer el presidente Gustavo Petro
pues me parece que desde el punto de
vista de Pedro él se quiere posicionar
internacionalmente hasta cierta medida
lo ha hecho pero como digo Juan Manuel
Santos cuando era presidente decía cosas
muy parecidas ahora si uno mira a nivel
de política de droga en Colombia Petro
no ha hecho realmente nada por
liberalizar la política no ha
introducido legislación tendría por
ejemplo para discriminar las drogas a
nivel Colombia tendría que cambiar el
código penal tendría que cambiar
una ley y no ha tomado ninguna medida
real entonces según lo que yo puedo
observar es pura retórica y bueno puede
que ocupe a Estados Unidos porque
mantiene esta postura de la guerra
contra las drogas Pero lo único que ha
hecho Pedro es decir que se requiere un
nuevo enfoque global a nivel de Naciones
Unidas decir que quiere armar un bloque
con otros países latinoamericanos en
Perú por ejemplo eso va a ser muy
difícil porque el actual presidente no
es de esa línea frente a las drogas
Entonces como digo creo que es pura
retórica y muy poca acción por parte de
Petro digamos que ese sería el enfoque
Ese fue el enfoque de la conversación de
blinken eh en territorio colombiano pero
en Chile Cuál sería la principal
prioridad de blinken con el gobierno de
borich Pues yo diría que el punto de la
gira es demostrar que Estados Unidos
está presente en la región recordemos
que chile hace unas semanas tuvo el
referendo donde una mayor mayoría
aplastante rechazó la nueva constitución
lo cual debilita a borich y creo que hay
un un intento por parte del departamento
de estado demostrar que Estados Unidos
igual está interesado en materia en
relaciones con con estos gobiernos pero
yo creo que hay que recordar que la
administración de biden es bastante a la
izquierda está bastante a la izquierda
en términos de la política de Estados
Unidos Entonces yo ya que hasta
simpatiza con con muchos de estos
gobiernos en materia a la crisis
climática global Daniel es que buscaría
el gobierno de Joe biden en
representación de Anthony blinken en
esta gira por estos tres países de
América Latina
pues tristemente En mi opinión
la lo que está haciendo Estados Unidos
hacia América Latina se enfoca en este
tipo de cosas como el tema del cambio
climático lo cual me parece que no es
una prioridad definitivamente para
América Latina y para países que entre
otras cosas emiten muy poco en términos
de polución es lo que debería haber creo
yo es una agenda bilateral mucho más
fuerte deberíamos tener tratados de
libre comercio mucho más robustos con
estos países ya los hay pero por ejemplo
en el caso de Colombia es un tratado muy
limitado muy proteccionista desde el
punto de vista colombiano entonces
habría que avanzar mucho más habría que
avanzar a crear una zona de libre
comercio continental Pero eso no le
interesa ni a los gobiernos de izquierda
proteccionistas en América Latina ni
tampoco le interesa a los demócratas en
este momento el tema del cambio
climático pues lo único que ha hecho es
causar esta crisis energética donde no
se ha invertido lo suficiente en los
últimos 10 o 15 años en la energía que
realmente funciona que
el gas y el petróleo y por eso tenemos
hoy en día estos precios tan altos y
esta crisis que está empeorando cada día
claro Daniel se lo comentaba también
porque hay varios países de nuestra
región líderes Mejor dicho de nuestra
región en Naciones Unidas en sus
discursos pues acusaron Estados Unidos o
ser uno de los mayores contaminantes que
así lo es ese si bien es cierto no
hacían como muchas políticas en nuestra
región o para mitigar estos efectos de
gases de efecto invernadero sobre todo
con la selva de la amazonía lo dijo el
presidente Gustavo Petro entonces que
qué políticas macros o enfocadas en
América Latina pudiera ser el gobierno
de biden para proteger estas zonas tan
importantes no para para el mundo y para
nuestra región
la amazonía Estados Unidos no tiene
parte de la Amazon claro entonces ahí lo
máximo que se puede hacer desde digamos
el primer mundo son políticas por
ejemplo de bonos de carbono que eso lo
venía haciendo Alemania por ejemplo
Entonces eso es una solución de Mercado
que es de lo más Sensato que hay pero de
hecho si uno mira Estados Unidos ha
reducido la la contaminación en los
últimos 10 años mientras que un país
supuestamente verde como Alemania por
estas políticas completamente
insensatas energéticas ha terminado por
aumentar su uso el carbón en esta crisis
por haber defendido completamente del
gas de Rusia y ahora están a punto de
congelarse al empezar el invierno
entonces realmente Estados Unidos ha
hecho mucho gracias al fracking y por
eso se han mantenido los precios
relativamente bajos porque podrían ser
mucho más altos si Estados Unidos no
fuera el principal productor de petróleo
hoy en día